I'm not a scholar of January 6. I don't
know I haven't looked at every piece of
evidence I've seen the Capitol Police
let people in the building I've seen
this guy Jacob chansley whatever is a
schizophrenic be led around the building
being led into all these locked areas by
the police why is a guy with horns not
being arrested why is he being led
around the capitol like a like a kid
who's having a Make-a-Wish at Disney
World this is like a schizophrenic
Make-a-Wish where he's being led around
the Capitol by the police and if you ask
about that or if you have any questions
about that and you want to know why
that's happening people just don't want
to engage they tend to shut you down and
I get it because at the end of the day
they're like we don't want to live in a
world where members of our government at
some level have agendas that are so dark
or show contrary to things we would
believe or understand and that terrifies
us